si on regarde ici au niveau du groupe
c'est à dire que si on regarde
maintenant d'essayer de visualiser
toutes les relations de ce groupe
donc qu'est-ce qu'on voit ici on voit
que notre notre prisonnier
voici monsieur pénale qui est ici
finalement il est membre d'un réseau
beaucoup plus important de personnes
interconnectés par des visites sur
lequel on est déjà identifié neuf
personnes qui font partie des bloods
trois qui font partie des crises de
failles plus hunters ici on a le nom des
prisonniers qui reçoivent des visites
par exemple parmi ce réseau vous avez
avait eu 12 4 et si on regarde cette
personne manière intéressante on voit
qu'elle reçoit la visite de sharon à
glendinning landes et non simple byzance
ces dons qui ce qui n'existe pas pour
les fins d'année la démonstration